[Music]
as per requested I'm going to start
covering a few more ninja bite builds
these won't be focused on specifically
running the resistance solo but there
will be a certain amount of emphasis on
ensuring that they're capable of it the
build I'll show in this video isn't the
only way of running resistance solo this
is just one of the many I've chosen to
start with this one because it also
offers another team role into the mix of
builds of shown so far the tank built in
this video I'll run you through the
build with the next video showing you
how to use it to found the resistance
mode solo and why the resistance because
currently this is the easiest most
consistent way for a solo player to get
classified gear outside of the global
events as a solo player running the
resistance or any other PvE game-mode
for that matter the number one priority
is staying alive in the solo build video
I talked about the Nomad builds constant
healing and extra life with this built
we're going to face tank though it can
be a little bit one-dimensional and play
style the d3 if in cease it really does
fill the role of making the user feel
like a tank it's focused mainly around
damage resistance and a ballistic shield
with the most notable feature being that
it allows the use of an SMG while also
holding the shield but staying alive
isn't quite enough we need to be able to
take down the NPC's particularly if
running the more difficult content so
special focus needs to be put into the
gear and weapon talents to ensure that
you have enough in the way of damage
output so that you can take down enemies
before they blast your way through your
shield this build isn't just useful when
run solo it also runs quite a useful
role when part of a team the shield's
default to hundred percent threatened
Crees will have most enemies targeting
you first allowing the rest of the team
to really crank out the damage with any
build video I post up you should be
using these as a guide only the
intention is for you to use them as a
starting point and then adapt them to
your style of play I'll do my best to
show a few different options within the
builds but you need to try these out and
make the choice for yourself as per
usual I'll be keeping this as short and
concise as possible at the end I'll have
a cheat sheet that will sum up the build
covered in this video please let me know
in the comments if I can provide a
little more detail
firstly you may have noticed that the
set pieces you see on-screen are
classified gear this is simply because
of the lack of stash base means that I
need to dismantle all non-classified set
pieces in order to have space for
everything the only difference in this
situation is that the classified gear
has slightly higher main attributes but
most of this is far from optimized so
the numbers you see here shouldn't be
far from what you can achieve with
non-classified gear this build consists
of three piece d3 if in C one piece
Nomad one piece technicians and the
ninja bike messenger bag I've tried
running this through the resistance
without a ninja bike bag just using the
four piece d3 FNC and it is possible to
open up a couple of the reward chests
but it's quite a bit more difficult with
the ninja bike we're gaining the four
piece d3 FNC two piece technicians and
two piece nomad bonuses skill haste and
health on kill this build heavily relies
on having that big fat bullet sponging
shield in front of you so if for some
reason it goes down it's quite important
that you get it back as quickly as
possible and this is where skill haste
is important but even with the shield up
you'll still have a certain amount of
damage landing on your body so health on
kill is also heavily required three
pieces have been rolled into stamina and
two into electronics this should leave
you with more than six case stamina and
around 5k electronics as the 4 piece D 3
bonus states ballistic shield health is
increased by 57 percent for every 30,000
stamina you could try for 9k stamina to
get the maximum out of this bonus but
you'd actually end up with less shield
health duty of skill power being quite
low so for this reason I'd recommend
aiming for 6 case stamina and putting
everything else into electronics in
skill power the other advantage to this
is that your second skill the support
station will come back faster and last
longer and you'll find this quite
important when running the resistance
skill power has been rolled onto the
kneepads and backpack with more skill
haste onto the chest and holster
enemy armor damage into the chest mask
and gloves and damage to elites onto the
mask and kneepads as per usual ammo
capacity has been rolled onto the chest
and backpack this is particularly
important with this build as you'll go
through a lot of Emma
as per the d3 set requirements you'll
need a good SMG I'd recommend the house
if you have one but an mp5 or org with
the right talents will do the job here
I'm using the mp5 St mine isn't the best
example as it has most of this talent
slot but I've used this to show that the
house isn't required in order for this
build to be successful some of the wit
and talents to aim for are destructive
for extra damage predatory to help keep
that constant flow of health
replenishment and responsive in the
third slot this is another good boost to
your damage particularly useful with
this build as most of your fighting will
be up close I recommend that your
secondary weapon is something with a bit
more range you'll only be using it four
times when you're dropping back into
cover to allow your shield to recharge
or if you're trying to conserve your SMG
mo in this example I'm using a
lightweight infall with destructive
predatory and determined so in this case
I'm also using it as a way to keep my
signature skills off cooldown
obviously the ballistic shield is a must
for this build I've used the mo cash
support station as the second skill
mainly for running through resistance
where mo doesn't drop from down DPC's so
it's quite necessary in order to slow
down your mo usage outside of resistance
you may choose to instead run something
like immunize ER or even the first ad
foe to help keep teammates on their feet
it's particularly useful with squishy
team members
the talents I'm running are combat medic
this is probably the most important
talent as this enables your mid kits to
be able to heal your shield with this
build the mid kits have better used for
healing your shield than your health
because generally if you have your
shield up your health won't be an issue
due to all of your health on kill perks
precision for extra damage this is quite
easy to proc with this build because
you'll be quite close to most enemies on
the move to reduce incoming damage after
killing an enemy and one is none again
because headshots are relatively easy to
land with this build this talent will
help reduce the amount of reloading and
ammunition you go through
the gear mods are firearms damage to
elites these could instead be swapped
out for electronics but I would still
keep these as damage to elites because
your firearms are so low you'll need
these talents to help increase your
damage over time the performance mods
are ballistic shield damage resilience I
highly recommend these because the
damage resilience is also applied to
your body when the shield is out this
has considerable impact on your overall
tankyness even if you're being flanked
you can take a lot more damage to the
body than usual
keep cover and walls behind you you're
strong but flanking is a very real
threat to this built it's important to
keep your shield up if you let it drop
you'll be vulnerable and you'll need to
wait 18 seconds before you can redeploy
it so instead of dropping it and running
for cover get into the habit of keeping
enemies in front of you and backing
yourself into cover under constant fire
the shield won't last forever so don't
forget to keep an eye on your shield
health and repair it using a mid kit all
utilize cover in order to give it a
chance to replenish you'll still take
quite a number of hits into the body but
as long as you're getting kills your
health will be at max if you want to
change weapons with the shield out for
example you want to change to a pistol
to conserve ammo or maybe swap to
another SMG you'll need to either inter
cover or enter the running animation you
can't change them over as usual while
the shield is out in front of you and
that's pretty much it try not to get
flanked keep an eye on your shield
health get kills to keep your health
topped up
this is a super easy bill to run but
this can sometimes make it a little
boring to play however if you have some
team members that aren't very well
geared this is one of the best types of
builds to carry people through missions
because you'll be attracting most of the
gunfire as I said at the start I'll be
releasing another video very soon
showing how this build can be run
through the resistance in order to farm
for classified gear but for now thank
you very much for watching this video
hopefully you found it useful and I'll
see you in the next one
Cheers
damnit
[Music]